let's go to our next caller from the
two-five three area code caller from -
5-3 introduce yourself tell me what does
on your mind today hey my name is also
David and I'm from Washington State
alright and as you know I have a
question about what you think about the
Republicans and repealing Obamacare
mm-hmm so as you know they've been
trying to do it and they sort of think
they're obligated to do it because Trump
and others campaigned on it yeah but it
seems like now that they're they've been
trying to repeal it it sort of brought
more people's attention to what the ACA
actually does and what it is yep and now
more people that realized maybe it isn't
as bad as the Republicans have been
saying it is for the last eight years
and so now the Republicans think they
should get rid of Obamacare even though
their constituents don't really seem to
want them to so my question is what we
what do you think is worse for the
Republican going into 2018 and 2020
right to go through with repealing
Obamacare or not - I have said a couple
of times now including earlier this week
that if Republicans ultimately don't
repeal Obamacare that there will be some
political liability because it's a
promise that they failed to meet however
you're spot on David in realizing that
actually repealing it will cause tens of
millions of people to end up without
health insurance and the repercussions
of that the political liability of that
could well be way bigger than not
keeping a campaign promise I mean let's
be honest a wall that Mexico is going to
pay for it's not going to happen a very
very long list of campaign promises that
won't happen not repealing Obamacare
will be yet another campaign promise not
met and I think that the fallout from
that will not be nearly as bad as what
will happen if they actually repeal
Obamacare and then tens of millions of
people end up without insurance so I
think that Republicans are actually
better off not that I'm giving them
advice right but I think that they are
politically better off not repealing the
Affordable Care Act especially since
even though it's a completely bogus
assertion you'll be able to convince
some trumpets that you weren't able to
do it because of Democrats I mean yeah
you control the House Senate in the
White House but some
trumpets or low information act that
they'll believe it's the fault of the
Democrats that they won't repeal it
right even though the Democrats weren't
involved in crafting the bill or never
even had a chance to vote on it
absolutely it was Republicans that
couldn't get on the same page
all right David thanks so much for the
call sounds like you've got a whole
thing going on there so I'll let you go
but I do appreciate the call very very
important topic and we're going to be
talking about health care a lot I
predict
over the next several years